here now is Rudy Giuliani mr. mayor
let's get your response to what madam
Clinton has had to say oh it's the most
incredible act of hypocrisy I've ever
seen I mean the woman basically voted to
give 20% of our plutonium to Russia her
crooked foundation got 150 million 150
million her husband got a 2.5 million
dollar speaking fee I don't know it kind
of looks like bribery it smells like
bribery it sounds like bribery I'm not
saying it is but it comes awful close
plus if anybody was guilty of
obstruction of justice it's her I mean
she did away with 33,000 emails she
destroyed phones
she had a guy doing with hammers and she
bleached bit her server president Trump
didn't do any of that in fact she's not
telling the truth he turned everything
over to the special counsel didn't
obstruct anything there's no obstructive
act that was found even by Muller
you know mr. mayor I was shocked that
she would even go there I mean in light
of the fact that she had these servers
what you just ran through that litany of
things that even Jim Comey went on
television to basically say yeah this
was stuff she shouldn't have done but
her intent wasn't there but basically he
outlined a criminal case for her and
then for her to come and do it I mean
that takes some real audacity don't you
think well Mike you know every one of
those acts I just mentioned is the
typical thing you prove as evidence of
intent there's nothing more powerful in
an obstruction case than destruction of
evidence which wasn't present in the
Trump situation nor was there an
underlying crime he was found to be
exonerated of collusion that whole
Russian thing turned out to be a hoax
she her campaign played a role in in
promulgating that hoax they paid 1.1
million dollars for the phony steel
dossier the only person who actually
apparently has done business with the
Russians if Hillary and I think she's
going to be in for quite a quite an
extensive investigation and she doesn't
have Jim Comey to fix the case for her
this time
mr. mayor the president weighed in on
this today he had a message to the
Democrat
it's in Congress silly non-congress and
it basically was this bring it on let's
watch get your reaction afterwards the
subpoena is ridiculous we have been I
have been the most transparent president
and administration in the history of our
country
I thought after two years we'd be
finished with it no now the house goes
and starts appealing they want to know
every deal I've ever done we're fighting
all the subpoenas look these aren't like
impartial people the Democrats are
trying to win 20/20 mr. mayor
the floor is your is your response well
this isn't completely political
harassment I mean anybody can see
through it
Jerry Nadler Schiff Cummings they've all
prejudge the case a year ago and
unfortunately because they have an
inability to control their mouths we
have plenty of statements that in that
hit that he's guilty of obstruction
guilty of collusion Adam Schiff has
evidence of collusion that he never
turned over to Muller apparently or he
was lying and one of the other so this
is the this is these are not impartial
arbiters and there's a very good ground
to resist these subpoenas as
illegitimate hearings by the by the cop
by the Congress this is a political
hearing it doesn't serve any legislative
purpose it doesn't really even serve an
investigative purpose Muller
investigated it to a fairly well and by
the way it's the second time an FBI
investigation cleared the president of
collusion how many times does he have to
be cleared of it so I would resist those
subpoenas and let them fight for
anything they get and prove it
legitimacy now one of the things they
want to subpoena is the the physical
body of Don McCann former White House
Counsel some of us are asking ourselves
I thought there were two things that
were sacred one was a husband and wife
testifying rights each other and the
other was that you cannot compel a
lawyer to come to testify against his or
her client so what am I missing
help me out here I'm not a lawyer I'm
proud to say so you helped me to
understand this well I fine
to be extraordinary their requests defy
every constitutional norm I can think of
the reality is that Cohen's rests the
attorney-client privilege when he taped
his client and lied to him about it and
then actually doctored the tape and
there's no reason to interrogate McGann
any longer he was questioned for 29
hours he must have given his entire
history going back to birth for 29 hours
and if mower couldn't get out of him
what he wanted it just isn't there so
this becomes now harassment it becomes
really a violation of separation of
powers Congress is going so far here
they are interfering with the ability of
the executive branch to function
81 subpoenas before the report was even
filed I mean they decided this before
they read the report Jerry Nadler was
overheard on the train coming down from
New York to Washington plotting an
impeachment and a week ago one of his
aides was heard doing the same thing so
they can go try to fool somebody else
but not Donald Trump so I guess I'm
having a hard time understanding an
impeachment is not going anywhere not
with the Senate in Republicans hands and
it's going to be a bigger failure than
it was with Bill Clinton in 1998 why did
the Democrats want to push it because it
actually helped Bill Clinton do they not
think the same thing will happen with
Donald Trump and let me make a
distinction Bill Clinton was guilty of a
crime it's called perjury
you know when the dress was produced he
had to stop lying about it otherwise
they'd still be lying at about about it
now and he and Hillary would be trashing
Monica Lewinsky but he got caught and he
had to admit that he committed perjury
lying under oath now maybe it wasn't
serious enough maybe it was more
personal but it sure was a crime so in
this case the president was found not to
have committed the underlying crime and
the reality is that the president's
conduct is easily explainable this is a
man who was falsely accused and
everything they like to say is
obstruction is a man trying to defend
himself against very unfair exaggerated
falsified Shar
yeah I think I'd be pretty ticked off if
somebody were accusing me of something
like that as well can't blame him